Charles Darwin was a big fan of billiards.
He loved his billiard table.
It was one of his prized possessions and one
of the most valuable things he owned.
Well - not the actual table itself. In fact,
it was the balls that were so valuable.
Pure ivory carved from the tusks of elephants;
only the wealthiest could afford a full set.
Luckily he was married to an heiress.
A full set of 16 billiard balls would require at least one, possibly two, full elephants worth of ivory.
The idea that any bar in the world might contain
a billiard table available for anyone to play,
and not like run out of the bar with your pockets full of valuable ivory would have sounded insane in 1850.
And the billiard industry was well aware of
this problem.
Billiard balls were getting more expensive,
elephants were getting more rare.
It was thus not with an environmental motive, that in 1867 the Phelan and Collender Pool Supply Company
offered $10,000 to anyone who could come up with a substitute material that worked as well as ivory,
but could be produced more quickly and sustainably
then dead elephants.
An inventor named John Wesley Hyatt took on
that challenge.
He used nitrocellulose, a flammable solid,
created by mixing cotton with nitric acid
to create a hard, shiny, white sphere.
The properties were extremely similar to ivory
billiard balls.
The company never gave him the prize.
But he did patent the technique, using it
to create billiard balls,
piano keys and even teeth, becoming pretty
dang wealthy in the process.
Also he pretty much created the industry that made all of the polymer materials that surround you right now,
and that we'll be discussing today in Crash
Course Chemistry.
Also elephants didn't go extinct, so that's
a plus.
[Theme Music]
The polymer that John Hyatt worked on was,
somewhat unsurprisingly, kinda crummy.
It worked well once it was created, but the
manufacturing process was dangerous
because nitrated cellulose can explode in
a warm breeze.
So luckily, some replacements started creeping
in.
Replacements with some names you probably
recognize, like polyvinyl chloride or PVC,
bakelite, polystyrene, polyester, and nylon.
These are all polymers; huge chains or sometimes 3D networks of repeating organic units called monomers.
Each polymer has a monomer, but they're all
relatively simple at that basic one unit level.
The trick is that they bond to each other
on each side potentially forever,
though in reality the chains are sometimes
hundreds, sometimes thousands,
sometimes hundreds of thousands of units long.
In order to make a polymer all you need is a molecule that can easily bond to another identical molecule at 2 points.
And the simplest of those is ethene, also
known as ethylene.
It's polymer, you'll be unsurprised to hear is polyethylene, which you've probably heard about.
We'll talk more about the specifics in a second,
but basically because pi bounds in the double
bond are weaker than sigma bonds
they can be broken and new monomers can be
added.
Just to note to avoid confusion: polyethylene
has that "-ene" sound in it, right,
but it's not an alkene because all those double
bonds get broken to form new sigma bonds.
It's a polymerized alkene, but the molecule
itself is an alkane.
It's confusing so I thought it's worth pointing
out.
Now chemists might want a bunch of different
things out of their polymers;
maybe they want it to be stretchy, maybe strong,
maybe transparent, maybe recyclable.
Polyethylene is transparent and thermoplastic, meaning it can be melted and reformed. Making it recyclable.
Some other polymers like polyurethane or Bakelite
are thermoset.
Which means that they change chemically during
some kind of curing process
and cannot be melted down and reformed.
Polyethylene can actually be converted into
a thermoset polymer by introducing cross-links,
basically molecular bridges between those
polymer chains.
Any plumbers out there probably have heard of cross-linked ethylene or PEX pipe. Which is what this is.
It's extra, super strong because of those
cross-links.
Polyethylene is also nice because it's strength can be varied by changing the size of the molecules.
If they are allowed to polymerize until they
are tens of thousands of monomers long,
the plastic they will form will be all knotted up in these ultra long chains and it will be extremely strong.
That's why this HDPE, high density polyethylene,
is a strong bottle.
Whereas this is much squishier, this is low
density polyethylene.
However those ultra long chains also make it much more viscous when heated and thus more difficult to process.
It also loses some of its opacity, and becomes
more of that milky white color.
Now polyethylene is great.
It's really great.
So great that it's the most common plastic in the world.
We produce over 80 million tons of it per
year.
But we want a lot out of our plastics - strength,
color, elasticity, resilience, recyclability -
we need everything from saran wrap to car
tires.
All of these are traits that chemists work tirelessly to create in the early to middle 20th century
and continue to work on even today.
One of the earliest techniques they used to
try and bring out new properties
was to change the substituents on the ethylene
monomer.
Just, see what would happen.
Like, what if we swapped out one of the hydrogens
for chlorine?
Well you get polychloroethene, kinda, that's
not what we call it.
OK, so remember how benzene when attached
to a chain is a phenyl group,
and how those two words have nothing to do
with each other?
Well the same thing goes for the ethene functional
group, which is called a vinyl group.
It's an old word, super old, it comes from
the Greek word for wine.
And that is why chloroethene is more commonly
called vinyl chloride.
And polychloroethene is more commonly called
polyvinyl chloride, or PVC.
Which is what this little ducky is made out
of and also what records are made out of,
which is why we call them vinyl.
Now what happens when we change out a hydrogen
for a methyl group?
Well then suddenly this molecule is a propene
or, if you are using ye old ways, a propylene.
And, yes, if you polymerize it, it becomes
polypropylene.
If one of the hydrogens is replaced with a
phenyl group,
well that chemical was first derived from trees in the Styrax family, so it's called styrene.
Polymerize it, polystyrene.
Make a foam out of it, Styrofoam.
Now if you change all four of the hydrogens on the base ethylene with fluorine it becomes tetrafluoroethylene.
Polymerize that and instead of hydrogens that
polymer is bound entirely to fluorines.
Fluorine as we could guess from its spot on the periodic table, love electrons. It is extremely electronegative.
But because it holds onto it's electrons so tightly, and is so satisfied in this polymerized chain,
the electrons are unavailable for even minimal
interactions with any other molecules.
I'm not just saying this stuff is super difficult to difficult to react with, or it's really stable.
It's more than that the electrons aren't even
available for the sort of interactions that
make things stick to each other, or cause
friction.
Which is why you have heard of polymerized
tetrafluoroethylene,
because it's super useful, either by its abbreviation,
PTFE, or by its brand name Teflon.
So how do we actually make these things?
Well, ethene based polymers form through a
process called addition polymerization.
The monomers are simply added together and
no by products are formed.
In order to get the process kicked off you
have to introduce a free radical.
To me, that always sounded like some crazy
freedom-fighter diving into battle
without much thought for what would come after
he was consumed in the firefight.
And, that's kinda what they are. Free radicals are atoms or ions that have a single unpaired electron.
This is crazy unstable. It's basically like having half of covalent bond dangling off the atom.
Anywhere this can form a bond, it's going
to form a bond.
And, in the case of addition polymerization it attacks the double bond and joins one of the carbons,
while the other carbon is itself left with
an unpaired electron.
The molecule itself is now a newly formed
free radical,
and it attack another nearby pi bond, joining with another molecule of ethene, forming another radical.
This process continues until two radicals
meet each other
consuming both free radicals without producing
any more, thus, ending polymerization.
There are, of course, other sorts of polymerization,
as well.
Sometimes a hydroxyl group from one molecule is happy to join up with a hydrogen from another, forming water.
The water will break away as a byproduct,
leaving the two molecules bound together.
This often occurs when an amine group, with
its loosely held hydrogen,
meets a carboxylic acid, with its loosely
held -OH group.
This is just what happens when hexamethylenediamine meets adipic acid forming another branded polymer, nylon.
By dissolving hexamethylenediamine and adipic acid into two different immiscible, or un-mixable, solvents,
we actually create nylon right here.
The nylon forms at the interface between the
two immiscible liquids.
And, we can literally grab it and pull it
out of the vial, twisting and spooling it
until we get a nice glob of nylon.
This works because hexamethylenediamine has
an amine group on each end
and adipic acid has a carboxylic acid on both
ends.
Thus when the two monomer unit, called a dimer,
is formed,
there is still a carboxylic acid on one end and an amine group on the other, allowing for further polymerization.
These amine acid condensation polymerizations
also allow for the creation of
possibly the most important polymers on the
planet;
natural polymers being created inside of youvright now out of monomers that we call amino acids.
Did you see that one coming?
Amino acids polymerize through condensation
reactions guide by the code in your DNA and
some very complicated enzymes to form basically
you.
Other important polymers in your body include:
polysaccharides, which we use to store energy;
and yeah DNA and RNA, which we use to encode
information for the formation of proteins.
But that would be back to biology, which is
a whole other Crash Course.
Which to be clear is available if you'd like
to watch it.
And thank you for watching this episode of
Crash Course Chemistry, in it you learned:
That the first commercial polymer ever saved
the lives of a lot of elephants.
That ethene is sometimes called ethylene.
And, that a huge variety of polymers is based on the addition reaction of ethene based monomers, including Teflon.
Which so friction-less because of fluorine's
extreme electronegativity.
You also learned how addition polymerization
reactions work.
And, that other polymers are formed by condensation
reactions.
Including the polymerization of amino acids monomers, which along with other polymers like DNA and RNA,
and glycogen, make up a lot of the stuff that
is you.
This episode of Crash Course was written by
me, Hank Green,
edited by Blake de Pastino, and our chemistry
consultant was Dr. Heiko Langner.
It was filmed, edited and directed by Nicholas Jenkins. Our script supervisor was Stefan Chin.
Our sound designer was Michael Aranda. And,
our graphics team is Thought Café.